Let's say we are simulating a nondeterministic RAM machine
inside of a deterministic RAM,
so the main cost of that is simulating the ifbetter function since
it's really the primary difference between
a deterministic RAM and a nondeterministic one.
But what exactly is the cost of simulating ifbetter?
Let's say we have a polynomial time algorithm,
and that algorithm uses ifbetter a constant number of times.
Then does that mean that the simulation on the
deterministic RAM takes a constant number of time,
a linear number of time, a polynomial amount of time,
or an exponential amount of time?
And similarly, if we use the ifbetter function
a logarithmic number of times in the input
or a linear number of times in an input,
and just for kicks,
let's do something a little bit more challenging.
How about if we use the ifbetter command
every 3rd instruction in the execution,
then how much time does this simulation cost us?
Please check once for each row.